this is a production of Cornell
University
this is actually only my second time -
do you work out on North Carolina so as
Larry mentioned I'm the vice president
of agronomy and outreach for a company
called criticality we're vertically
integrated processing company in the
state of North Carolina we have
operations in four states currently our
partner who purchased 40% of us back a
couple of years ago is a company that
you probably haven't heard of yet called
Texas international they are a legacy
tobacco company with operations in 30
different countries they've kind of grow
a network that really spans the globe
and really having their partnership is
what enables us to do what we do across
the country and also it helps with our
being able to participate in research
like Larry's so it's been a lot of fun
so far and as Larry kind of alluded to
one of the key things in achieving
profitability and making sure that you
don't lose money on him is finding a
company that's trustworthy that you can
contract with so there is going to be a
surplus this year I can I can assure you
of that however a lot of that is because
several companies are out there
contracting thousands and thousands of
acres with no real commercialization
plan and understand that it takes a lot
of money to commercialize that amount of
acreage and you're looking as you're
looking through this budget that I
passed out on the back page there's
there's a table that assumes about half
a pound of formal material per plant
so about a thousand about a thousand
pounds of floral material per acre on
our model that we're using in North
Carolina and you can see as your CDV
percentages go up this is assuming three
dollars and fifty cents per percentage
of Sidi per pound you can see as those
percentage points go up the monetary net
value to the grower goes up pretty
dramatically - and taking a look at
those gross numbers so this is on a per
acre basis so if you had growers that
were achieving a thousand pounds of
floral material per acre at 10 percent
cbdu I as a company have to pay out
thirty five thousand dollars per acre
now think about that for a second so my
company has to shell out thirty five
thousand dollars per acre so we're
contracting a thousand acres what is my
cash flow situation have to look like to
be able to pay you the growth so that's
that's problematic suit honestly the
first thing that you as a grower need to
do to achieve profitability in your crop
is sign a contract with the company that
you knew as has the monetary resources
to pay you at the end of the season it's
been a huge problem in North Carolina I
would say probably 40 to 50 percent of
growers over the past two years have not
been paid for their crop and a lot of
them are still sitting live now in a lot
of situations you can get sort of pulled
into a situation where you are going to
get Dave but maybe you're getting paid
half and oil well and and that's fine if
you have a commercialization plan for
that
if you're planning on starting your own
brand something like that
that that might be fine in your business
model but understand if you're planning
on supplying that oil as raw ingredient
to a formulator generally speaking
formulators that are buying dramatic
amounts of raw ingredients don't want to
piecemeal it from form to form and then
another thing that you have to take into
account is a looming regulation
once the FDA gets involved with this
everybody's everybody used may be
factoring products from these from these
oils is going to have to comply with 21
CFR part 111 or 117 whichever day
whichever it shakes out to be and
there's a cost associated with that
regulatory burden and it's not an
insignificant cost so as you're planning
what you're going to do with your form
just make sure you're taking these
things into account in your business and
and this is not a cheap crop to raise
you can look through here in this budget
and assuming $4 per plant if you're on a
little by 6 facing witch's typical down
in North Carolina
depending on your planting date just
your plant cost per acre is going to run
you to 7 up $7,200 that's on a per acre
basis base so this is not achieved crop
to raise if you're raising it personally
thank you get into things like
analytical testing fees so we have $300
down here for
festivities I would assume that if
you're doing it right you're probably
gonna spend significantly more then $300
on those testing fees but then if you go
over to the next page where it really
gets here here's where on your arm you
can make the most impact in your cost of
production right now and that's long
labor costs so there are a lot of
innovative things coming out right now
Randall equipment which anyone near
familiar with company called Randall
equipment I figured probably not they're
bigger than two back this space so
they're out of Roxboro in one Carolina
they recently came up with a piece of
equipment that essentially bucks
the crowd on a massive scale so it
dramatically mechanize --is the
operation as far as removing a plural
material furnace stocks and you can see
in here
so your total labor costs if you're
doing everything by hand and all of
these numbers were generated from
sitting down with our growers and
putting a really sharp pencil to what
their costs were over the past couple
years so you can see if you're doing
everything by hand you're looking at
forty one hundred and seventy dollars as
far as your labor costs from start to
finish that grain whole piece of
equipment to cut your labor costs down
to thirteen hundred fifty seven fifty
now that's a dramatic savings understand
that that piece of equipment cost forty
two thousand dollars but just in labor
savings alone if you have fifteen acres
of hemp out in the field that piece of
equipment pays for itself year one in
labor savings this market is going to
continue to commoditize as these
products become more readily available
as your material comes onto the market
the price is going to continue to go
down so if you as a grower need to be
thinking right now how you were going
to reduce your cost in reducing this
crop over the next few years and so some
of those some of those input costs are
starting to take care of the results
we've seen in North Carolina clones go
from up to fourteen dollars a plant in
2016 the first year of our program down
to four dollars a plant this year now a
lot of that was collective negotiating
on on our part
fourth row the base but understand those
those prices are coming down and
honestly I feel I feel that the biggest
way to cut your costs in planes right
now is to go to sea there are a number
of reputable seed companies out there
producing ICBC or an in CBD happens to
be what a lot of our growers are using
currently but going from seed and going
from even a $4 clone to $1 seed is a
dramatic savings for you were on now
understand that and I don't know I don't
know if Larry's tried it at all but
nobody that I know of has had success in
direct seeding these so that dollar per
plan is not going to be your all-in cost
in your plants generally speaking you're
going to have to make a transplant out
of those seeds but even if you're a
dollar twenty-five an all-in that's
better than $4 per plant
soon magnetization plant costs that is
the those are the two biggest ways right
now you as a grower can start dropping
your cost in this crop does that make
sense to everyone does anyone have any
questions on that what was the name of
the Machine again so granbull equipment
is the company and it's actually gotten
on here I think they're just calling it
there a hint Thrasher but they have a
website if you google it we'll pull it
right up
any other questions yes ma'am
[Music]
yes ma'am I Oregon CBB takes a lot of
pride in what they do they only put out
f1 seeds and their varieties have in
multiple states met that legal threshold
for several years now and that brings up
that brings up a good point because you
can get online right now and find 15
different seed companies how do you know
which of them were recognized well
that's kind of difficult right now I'll
tell you that
Oregon's CBD twice this past year
crashed their website and made 8 million
dollars in three minutes when they
released seed on our website that tells
me that they're probably fairly
reputable they have actual sales we have
folks that add these varieties out the
field right now and they've performed
well the past couple of years so as
you're going through your vetting
process for their farming just do as
much research as possible as to who's
grown those varieties who's bought seed
from that company because there are a
lot of horror stories out there right
now
[Music]
[Music]
yeah the question was are a lot of these
growing practices varietal specific and
do those different varieties have sort
of a different place in the market
moving forward and I absolutely think
that they do soon you're starting to see
more folks put research into CBG
dominant right it's been to see BC
dominant varieties and that's that's
gonna play a huge role in the market
moving forward because CBD is to
monetizing isolated CBD is actually
selling at a decent premium right now
but the cheapest way to get large
amounts of CBG is not to isolate it out
of the extract from CBD dominant
varieties because you're talking about
fractions of a percentage point as far
as your yield off of that extraction the
the cheapest way and the best way to
commercialized those other cannabinoids
is to go through a breeding process and
get plants that are dominant in the in
the production of those cannabinoids now
I don't think that we're quite there yet
but it's coming and I think and I think
that's a very good point to think about
as you were thinking about your plan for
your fall thanks for your question all
right
yes sir so question was is an indoor or
greenhouse environment environment
better for acidity production and I'll
tell you this as far as controlling it
for contaminants it's definitely
beneficial but it just costs us thinking
much more and as this continues to
monetize now there's certainly there's
certain market segments that are
probably going to demand that in order
production but they're very small market
segments if you can find one of those
market segments that works for you and
your farm and then I'd say go for it but
with the cost of lighting honestly right
now if you're just selling the company
this processing for CBD it's probably
not it's probably not profitable and it
probably is going to get less profitable
as as it continues to monetize
well so we don't we don't do any kind of
this moment products my company doesn't
like those products make up about 20% of
the products that are on retail sale
shelves in North Carolina right now and
when you're talking about a smokeable
product if it absolutely has to be
produced in a controlled environment to
mitigate things like you know mold
mycotoxins things like that so it's much
easier to control that in a greenhouse
or better yet a full-on annual Road
facility than it is outdoors
yes sir
[Music]
question was is the drying and
harvesting process standardized or is it
evolved that the quick down and dirty
answer is it's definitely evolved I can
tell you what's working for us in North
Carolina right now there's not a lot of
mechanization as far as the purpose is
concerned most folks early cut the
plants by hand but there is a
significant amount of infrastructure
particularly in Eastern North Carolina
that's been transferred from the tobacco
industry into the hemp industry so we
have these things called all corns and
what it is is it's it's it's a it looks
like a shipping container but you're
forcing air through the product whether
it be tobacco now and you can add heat
to it too
so with these tobacco arms which are
already on farm in North Carolina you
can take a crop that's 40 percent
moisture in the field and dry it down to
eight percent moisture which is optimal
for our extraction methodology in about
three days and and it really helps
mitigate development of mold and things
like that
after you've harvested we had a lot of
guys our first year that tried to just
hang it up and let it dry naturally and
unfortunately I think you guys have the
same problem up here as humidity is
certainly not conducive to it and you
develop a quite a dramatic amount of
time so really now I see folks I've seen
folks do the same thing in this week
date here
facility works just as well I can't tell
you that one way of drawing it's better
than the other all I can give you is
what's working for our workers right
yes ma'am
[Music]
hey no man they're putting coal blanks
in these tobacco ponds and then they're
stripping it post drying it's a lot
easier to strip the dry material than it
is to strip the wet material yes sir
yes
production is going to be that spider
company - esta sign contract
and so if you want yeah that's that's a
real good question I really I don't know
if you know this split as far as CBD
versus grain and fiber I tend to really
just focus on the CBD economics I can
tell you that I would assume that a
dramatic amount of that 400,000 acres is
for acidity the vast majority of it
because the markets just really haven't
been developed for green fiber down here
in the US yet you have some companies
like son strand who has facilities up
and running both in the US and in Canada
and I think in Uruguay - at this point
that are working on commercializing
fiber but through the markets just
aren't there yet and excuse me what was
secondary quit again oh the contracts
the contracts soon we contracted out a
bridge across four states this year and
we sign a binding contract with our
growers that they they will receive
three dollars and fifty cents per
percentage point of dry or per
percentage point of CBD by dry weight
per pound of material eight percent is
considered drug yep that's what those
numbers are based on those numbers are
based on our contract price yes sir
[Music]
yeah and and that's that's good if you
have any of land that is that is a good
niche to go forth
we did some certified organic
contracting this year and it was it a
multiple of that number but I think some
folks purse were disappointed in the
multiple because if you're talking about
organic tobacco versus conventional to
that it's usually a 1.8 X multiplier on
the price well artists artist wasn't
anywhere near a 1.8 X multiplier because
essentially you're our production
methodology even if you're
conventionally producing this product
you're still using mostly organic
practices really really what we're
paying a premium for is the
certification so it definitely was
worthwhile and we got in participation
and that but it's it's nowhere near you
know two times the contracted price
well and and realistically the question
was about pulling the pool material off
the flames
pre-drying and you know I'm not going to
tell you that that doesn't work but it's
much easier for our growers to throw the
whole plant in a tobacco barn and then
as they're pulling the plants out of the
tobacco morning they're stripping the
whole material law and then packaging it
to come to us and that mitigates a lot
of your concerns with hope because
you're going straight from that
controlled environment directly into the
package to us
now really really haven't had any
problems with that civil yes sir
so the question is are there set
parameters for drying the plant as far
as temperature humidity things like that
once again I can't tell you that it's
locked down to the science right now
what's working for our guys is pushing
air that's that's about 10 degrees above
ambient and that is generally mitigating
a lot of those humidity concerns
[Music]
I've seen I've seen self dehumidifiers
used but in this tobacco arms if you're
adding a little bitty and keeping the
air the temperature of that air that
you're forcing through the product about
ten degrees above ambient pressure and
not running the air when it's raining
outside or something like that generally
that's gonna keep your humidity fairly
low one more question yes ma'am
so a very good question who's
responsible for the transportation and
right now the growers are responsible
for the transportation what I can tell
you is we're looking at logistical
solutions to make that easier on growers
so for instance moving into a market
like New York right just just the same
way that our partners - in tobacco what
we're looking at is setting up the
remote buying stations in those
different markets that were contracting
it we're not quite there yet
but I would assume that next year or the
year after as we continue to expand if
we continue to expand that's going to be
the bomb thank you all very much
I'll be around
[Applause]
okay we're gonna kick off our discussion
of research with two folks looking at my
lab they're gonna tag-team this
presentation talking about our results
from our CBD hemp trial from last year
and some of the concerns that you should
have about acquiring C and achieving
compliance for THC so George George
stack just graduated with his Bachelor
of Science from Cornell so he's actually
talking about work that he did doesn't
undergraduate in my lab and he will tag
team with Jacob toe who is a new PhD
student torch also is about to start his
PhD so George so they are working off of
a handout that we gave out the 2018 in
Albemarle introduction and OH
all right I remember hearing good I am
so dignified are you talking about -
I'll actually preset the trial that we
conducted last summer last summer
respect all right that we conducted last
hour across New York State and that we
ended up qualifying cannabinoid scores
so we'll break down those two sets of
trials two major sets of frauds first
one was the raven fiber a new purpose
trial which had 33 different varieties
from the united states canada and europe
in it it was hit six times across the
state yellow dots on the map there so
twice in Geneva
twice in Ithaca once in cheesy and 1/7
Long Island upriver heads we covered the
entire to blue greens in New York State
and you'll hear more about that from
Jamie this afternoon that was planted
direct seeded with a small plot brain
drill four reps walked into early
maturing grain dual purpose grain and
fiber varieties and later maturing final
rites that was planted in the middle of
tune and orcid throughout September the
other major said the problem we did was
a cannabinoid trial with groups
replicated twice once in Tunisia once in
Ithaca so those were transferred to
greenhouse and transplanted into black
plastic there was 15 different varieties
started in that trial they were sorted
from based male and female seeds all the
plants were transplanted into the field
and then the males were called out in
the field and then towards the end of
the year once the plants were flowering
we collected floral tissue for canal
burn analysis and there was kind of
different reasons we did that one was to
measure THC which is important for
staying under regulatory levels the
other measuring CBD which is important
because that's your bottom line that's
where you're going to be paid for and
then the third was measuring other minor
cannabinoids which kind of Scott alluded
to and his talk to see if there is any
potential for liens that would be better
producing those plan accountants so I'm
going to turn it over to ticket to talk
about our HPLC and thank you doing so as
I was mentioning we as HPLC to measure
the command waits or our various
different entries we tested CBE THC CDC
CBP and their corresponding assets we
also tested Delta H THC and CBN but we
didn't find any of those notes in eight
of our samples to calculate the total
potential we multiplied the
corresponding acid former THC or CBD by
point 877 and that's what's shown in our
clock at the bottom of the page so the
great fiber and dual these are sort of
representative samples from ten clients
ten female plants that we harvested
while the CBD and pollination trials
were the averages of individual plants
as you can see we had some grain fiber
and dual cultivators that
above the legal limit of point three th
see the dotted line there is three total
potential THC and if you look at our CDE
variety is everything to test it hot so
looking at the individual plants in the
CTD trial we found three distinct groups
if you plotted the total potential THC
versus total potential CBD and that's in
the scatter plot in the other bottom
corner the first group is in red and it
was mostly th see very little CED we
were talking about the marijuana Titan
on the second grouping green had about
equal amounts of THC and CBD we're
calling that the heterozygous nitrous
and then the third wound and blue is
about 20 to 25 to 1 CBD to THC
using published genetic data on the gene
sequences of the cannabinoid cervezas
they were able to develop an elective
America which mapped on directly to
these three groups and that's what gives
you the color there so what we can say
summarized in the first paragraph
it looks like the marijuana types to
marijuana poppies the heterozygous have
one marijuana coffee
and then the hem types have to attempt
copies so what was really interesting
here is that we've found a pretty
consistent 20 to 25 to 1 ratio in the
hem type so that means if we're going
for a point three percent total
potential THC we can't get much for
around 6 or 7 percent total CDE without
getting above 23 percent total potential
THC which is very large so if this is
follicular marker one thing that we
thought that was very interesting with
that these heterozygotes in nearly every
culture that we tested the only test
it's a few customers and they're listed
on the back but with I don't think
there's any reason to suspect that those
are special in being any cultures that
are going to be segregated for this
marijuana type cannabinoid synthase it
in case it's going to be a future
breeding effort of ours to make sure
that all future varieties are going to
be actual and
and George talked about that point you
say yeah so the the third trial that we
did was just in Geneva lust last summer
and we were looking at how distance from
a pollen source affected cannabinoid
content which is a pretty important
concern I'm sure many of you are
familiar that there's anecdotal evidence
that once cannabis plants are pollinated
their levels of cannabinoids go down
dramatically so we decided to conduct
this trial last year to to gauge maybe
how far or how much of a decrease
farmers could expect that there is
pollen source near their field so what
we did is we planted a three acre plot
of a Canisius dual-purpose brain and
fiber variety called Wonka you can see
that in the center of the map on the
back of your handout there and then we
put many smaller micro clocks in the
four cardinal directions around the plot
so we had the controls a ring at 207 501
at 1500 in the NARC or cannabinoid CBD
trial was now on the map but further
away container so now I'll point it down
to that my scatter plots on the bottom
so the first one on the left you can see
as the distance from the pollen source
increase the number of seats decreased
which is what we expected it means that
less pollen was probably getting to
those plots that were further away they
were getting less pollinated the middle
cloth there as the number of seeds on a
plant increase the total potential CBD
decreased another thing that we expected
you know as the plants got more
pollinated they had lower levels of
cannabinoids and then the last term on
the left there
as distance from the pollen source
increase total potential CBD increased
so the plants that were further away got
less pollinated at I have my bonus you
see we had a little blip at our 1,500
plot because a lot of them were stolen
you know general upward trend net
already
so Jacob I'm happy to be happy to take
any questions any of our trial
[Music]
yeah so we were doing our testing based
on the regulatory standard for New York
State which is the top ten centimetres
of a floral tissue by the plant we dried
up in a greenhouse and then modernized
it in nutribullet and then we sent it to
the HPLC
[Music]
[Music]
it doesn't actually oh so the question
was does the grouping at all match in
the covers a sativa so we we are really
concerned you know reading context or
testing about in the covers a sativa I
think the most recent genetic evidence
suggests that those aren't truly
taxonomically relevant but the grouping
here it was a lot of within culture
rearrangement some calls burrs did have
more heterozygotes than others
but with in nearly every call Turner
just looking at Delta 9 THC alone or
looking at potential everything in the
blue group was well below about half of
the group was below marijuana threats
were always above so we tested for a
belt and I and Delta 8 and HDA and
what's on the is total potential which
is Delta 9 + 0 8 7 7 times th da thanks
for scaring me it is not yes it was the
last year that's what we found in last
year's study it's not necessarily the
case for every plant they're coming
golfers than we have he tried but
everything that we've seen has a ratio
of around 20 to 25 so up to 27 we didn't
see much higher ratio than that
so so the question is at what point do
you request the regulatory sampling okay
you have to be compliant at the time of
the regulatory sampler
and then you harvest up to three weeks
after let me will accumulate after that
regulatory samples like
I'm Jacob
excellent point it is the ratio of see
need to th seed that is critical and we
are seeing at best about 25 to 1 ratio
so if you go for a 12.5% CBD crop you're
at 0.5 percent THC and you're
non-compliant so my recommendation would
be don't get greedy don't get greedy
test regularly ask for the regulatory
sample at the proper time so that you
stay compliant one more question
[Music]
but the loss of that point is there
anything in place that could potentially
use that crap for fire or anything
otherwise it's just sorry
see you next year so the question is if
you are above the legal regulatory level
is there anything you can do with that
Prop yes the answer is no it's gonna be
cease to destroy okay thanks a lot
Jacob in Georgia and any great job
you know the title is an algorithm
disease resistance
if you're having trouble fighting it the
one with a lot of authors because we had
a lot of great people working on this
project besides me
so one of the major diseases that were
interested in in is powdery mildew so
this disease is caused by a public
pathogen it shows up as these white
spores these patches on the leaves which
you can see in bigger ones and the these
patches can spread and go onto flowers
and reduce your flowers but quality
which you can see in Virginia and then
figure Korean or are just zoomed in
versions of those spores that are
causing this disease so right now there
isn't really established disease
management for better you it's something
that were working in right now there
aren't any fungicides but that's also
something we're working on so but
another way that we're working on this
looking for resistance so we evaluated
30 ICD bars to look for resistance
that's building so that is shown in at
the bottom of the page so we earn these
30 cultivars we took three leaves from
each of the cultivars and inoculated
them with the powdery mildew in the lab
and then we rated for disease severity
by looking at the microscope and county
pinkie and our results you can see in
the graph in figure 5 so we saw some
differences there are certainly some of
the cold words that are more susceptible
to the powdery and this is something
that we're going to continue to do with
more polymers
right now we're doing the screening you
would Tom Brady and Piper cultivars so
that's something that we're going to
continue to work on so so that's what
we've done so far and you turn to the
back there is we're talking about cross
infectivity you would pop I don't know
move and have a party to do so you
anything you are we talked about haha
right well hop is actually the most
closely related from species to them and
it has its own powder you later pops by
quickly these different genus and
species of fungus and you can see ha
leaf infected with powdery mildew in
figure 6 and if your second is also and
they top it's a top flower or
cone and also infected with powdery
mildew so we were wondering because
these crops are so closely related can
their powdery mildews infect each other
so it's not powdery mildew a threat to
hop and then in figure 8 you can kind of
see that top hem programmatic doesn't
really grow that great have fought
another do that grow great on so so it
doesn't seem like anything's gonna be
that big of a threat to hops but in
figure 9 you can see that hop powdery
mildew grows quite well on this
particular cultivar of hemp inca so that
is something that we are interested in
looking into further is there any
resistance in tend to both tempt other
can do it
are there any recent games and if so
which cultivars are resisted and how can
we incorporate that into the breeding
program
there the question is is there anything
that can be sprayed for this right now
and the answer is no there's no nothing
that is appropriate not to be sprayed
that's something that fits yeah
so I along with the Department of Ag
markets have been working with the New
York State Dec and about two weeks ago
we had a phone call with them and they
are working to create a list of products
that will be legal to use on him
and I asked if that list would be ready
this season and there's once was witness
the season end but I have to say it was
a really productive conversation the Dec
understands the need for both organic
and conventional products the need for
products to be used in Disease Control
and and I think they are working on a
list of products that will be available
for use hopefully before the end of this
season and not that it's entirely
helpful but certainly by next season
completely different genus and species
that creates it on the hop plant versus
the hemp plant is there a possibility
that it's just because this plant isn't
growing out here at all and that says
other hands that's usually bad for hops
could potentially watch this crap
becomes more mainstream and adapt and
become an issue since they're so closely
related
[Music]
methods are really adaptable that's what
their Jeannette and absolutely if you
have a larger target area and you know
powdery mildew makes millions and
millions and millions of spores every
year of course the possibility exists
right now we primarily have seen every
mildew in greenhouse scenarios and not
as often in the field but having said
that if any of you have seen powdery
mildew in your temp field and we would
love to have what we alley would love to
have a sample what we want to do is look
at the diversity of this pathogen across
New York and across the country to see
if how similar it is adversities and and
in our in our circle let me rephrase and
Hallie search for resistance it we want
to make sure that if a cultivar is
resistant to one strain we know if it's
resistant to all of the strains or if
it's strain specific to the power
[Music]
so that's something that we're gonna be
looking into so we haven't collected or
cbdu yet this year so that's something
that we will be looking to do it so we
have a harvested them yet maybe we'll
have that information
energy
it's been my experience that a plant
breeder always tells in five years five
years three five years so it depends on
the genetic mechanisms of resistance so
we have to broadly two mechanisms of
resistance it's a single gene that's
conferring resistance that single gene
can be fairly easy to incorporate into
analyze if it's a multi genic mechanism
that can be very challenging a very long
term process but that mechanism is more
stable what I think I should mention
that Ali is doing that she would bring
up is we are we here on research land
testing different products and spurring
them on plants that
they'd be approved for use in the future
to see if there's final toxicity but
also to see if any of the products that
may be approved cause modifications in
THC or CBD levels because really nothing
is known about it even if you use an
organic product which frequently are
living bacteria that secrete antibiotics
that kill powdery mildew we don't know
what that does to THC or CBD
concentration in the flowers so that's
one of the important things that we do
looking at are you seeing any evidence
or tracking lights at this point
question is are we tracking we're
probably differentiation
our schedule today Dennis with who is a
new assistant professor in the
Department of Entomology here at Cornell
Agrotech unfortunately he fell ill this
morning and is in the hospital
so Camellia go Garris in his lab is
we're handing out her hands up right now
and we'll talk about the work in
Dennis's lab to characterize secondary
products and terpenes
so talking lovest we were trying to
understand how plants and insects can
communicate using chemicals and why I'm
here because those chemicals computer
things are very important for understand
those communications wives are things
where things are small levels and they
are important for two reasons first
because it's our twin defense they are
very important to understand and the
question depends against insects Oh
pathogens for stress and the other thing
that is very important in the Turkmen
sequence plants including young is this
alien taste so in a bunch
without the plants and how those amongst
our how the needs with compounding
points their response now we are doing
some work with Chris Martinez Bert when
we are trying to understand which pom
pom which terpenes are involved for the
camp for the taste and the smell of the
rim because something very important and
how the skin influenced the pathogens
and then it blends the camp with insect
and stress but to do this we just
collect some plant samples can be the
whole or we just live here around
we have their message expectrum are the
chromatography when we analyze those
chemicals and we can quantify that by
all those notes with this we can test
those compounds and we can see exactly
what
which one is influence the results or
the preference or the defense basically
the idea with our work with that just
importance
on the
look a bit here we have some examples
with certain things that you can find at
the encampment and I bring some vials
with each receipt or smell and I think
you guys are really exactly the same
smell for the ramp because normally it's
a combination with different by
different numbers of surveys some most
of the times when we take the sample
from the plants we have no idea we are
trying to figure out the terpenes that
we can find and with
seem to tie those two things and test
those their pains against whatever we
want to smell it takes
that have some turbines that we can find
but and we are working with some species
now but we don't tell exact things
specific
it's the thought that you will identify
the Furby that repelled specific and
stuff I'm done genetically create a plan
if our goal is trying to get my son
surfing that can be usable for the best
patron yes normally it's not just one
it's a combination and we have different
ways that you can apply those two things
on the plants can be a genetic thing or
can be just directly spray of the plants
and this plant can sensitize or you can
stimulate the plants produce those two
things yes now or it is just a identify
first and after death trying to
stimulate the plants to do something and
we can use the genetic things to do or
we tend to use the different
[Music]
I'm not sure
[Music]
yeah so the question is are there
correlations between particular turkeys
and particular cannabinoids and there
was a very nice paper done that
Washington State it was just published a
couple months ago to characterize that
and I'm trying to remember Jacob might
remember better than I I do not recall
that they sell specific correlations
between particular terpenes and
particular cannabinoids those were in
marijuana types it's why
[Music]
I I don't think help something that we
do we don't do anything but this yes we
are just working with the basic things
and try to identify the through things
but I'm sure we'll within some next step
thanks very much this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu